and the reason that justin herbert is
going to be playing tyrod taylor's not
available the reason he's not available
is because man he had a reaction
reaction is the kindest way to put it to
a pain killing injection that was given
to him last sunday so that he could play
with a rib injury the reaction happened
because the needle was inserted into his
lung the nfl players association is
investigating the situation and look i'm
no medical expert but i know there are
certain medical outcomes that no one is
responsible for and then there are
medical outcomes that are avoidable
sticking the needle into the lung is
something that would seem to be on the
avoidable side of the ledger here
are anthony lynn and hunter henry from
the chargers chargers tight end talking
about the medical staff in the aftermath
of the error that resulted in tyrod
taylor having a punctured lung
i'm not angry at all you know
[Music]
it happens you know and uh like i said i
can't go into details about it but uh uh
it was a complication with the shot and
you know no one's perfect you know uh i
don't think anyone in this zoom is
perfect so it happens but i know the
doctors i know he's a good man and uh
um it's just unfortunate um i still have
faith in our our medical staff i think
we're you know obviously this is an
unfortunate event and um this is this is
that you know it's not it's not good and
i know none of us think it's good at all
but
we're going to continue to move forward
and i do have faith in them
look i i agree no one is perfect and i
am uh one of the prime examples of that
but there are certain professions where
mistakes have greater consequences
that's one of the reasons why
i love what i do now so much more than
what i used to do because when you're
practicing law if you screw something up
you're screwing up someone else's
interest yeah in this context if i make
a mistake if i say a word wrong if i get
a report wrong it's on me right i can
live with that right when you're
sticking a needle into someone's body
in the vicinity of internal organs
i look you don't have to be perfect but
you got to be better
than putting the needle into the guy's
lung so and i understand from coach
lin's perspective there's a very real
liability
concern and the organization probably
doesn't want him going out there saying
man we got some quacks on this staff uh
and hunter henry you know he gave the
perfunctory we have faith and then and
then the rest of his explanation showed
that they really don't and what other
choice do they have yeah
these are the cards that they've been
dealt you know these are the people are
going to be taking care of you you don't
want to throw them under the bus when
you may need them
this weekend but the bottom line is this
is unacceptable and you know it's
amazing it's not amazing because social
media you're going to have someone who
supports every point of view possible
even on
topics where there should not be a
second point of view on this topic there
should not be a second point of view you
don't puncture someone's lung with a
needle and if you've done that this
isn't within the normal risks to be
assumed of getting a painkilling
injection yeah or you probably wouldn't
do it
no i i mean you're right
it's bad it's unlucky i mean first off i
feel horrible for tyrod taylor i mean
the guy just continues to
you know fight club be a professional do
all the things the right way and just
can't catch a break so i really do like
feel for him
now the second thing is yeah rib injury
that area
that's a tough area and for a
quarterback
it can really bother you because of
course you're twisting and torquing to
throw
your arm is flexing back which also
causes a collapse of the ribs and things
like that in that area i've had some
banged up ribs before and man it was
just bruises and things and it hurt to
throw the football so and then there's
not a lot of room for error there right
like i mean as you know if you had a
ribbit thing that's like okay yeah it's
the ribs and then you get through there
and you're gonna start to get into lungs
and
and that's just
yeah it's bad i don't know what to say i
know that the doctor certainly didn't do
this intentional but yeah there's no
excuse for it and just like we talked
about the 49ers having like the turf on
their issue or on their head as far as
an issue
the chargers player's gonna be thinking
the same things oh wait we're supposed
to get an iv wait is it from you know dr
needle over there who punctured the lung
can we have something else
i'm sorry oh doctor needle because that
happened in my tampa bay locker room
once with the guys where
guys didn't feel comfortable and there's
no there's more than one doctor around a
team too so you just start don't take
anyone but doctor you don't want dr
needle and you know i'm sure he's
probably got a nickname already in the
locker room whether he likes it or not
and i know this human is probably a very
good doctor and good person and
everything like that he made a bad
mistake and i'm sure he feels horrible
about it and i feel bad for tyrod taylor
uh you know there are five football
injuries that i can personally relate to
the sprained ankle the calf strain the
hamstring injury and the final two
broken ribs and bruised rib cartilage
which are equally painful right but i
fell down a hill when i was 14 and i
broke three ribs and you can't do
anything you can't sleep that's how
painful it is you get hiccups god i
learned how to make hiccups go away with
the power of my mind that's how painful
hiccups are when you have broken ribs so
i can only imagine trying to do the
things that quarterback does and you
know that's the thing we hear about pain
and it's funny because
earlier this week sean mcvay was talking
about cam akers the rookie running back
he's got separated rib cartilage it's
not broken so you don't have the risk of
a rib breaking off and you know
puncturing an organ that way not with a
needle the old-fashioned way with a
piece of a rib right but you know that
oh yeah he'll be able to play through
the pain yeah because they're gonna
stick a needle into the area and numb it
that's the dirty little secret that you
always talk about whether it's a
localized pain killing injection or the
full body toradol thing these guys are
pumped full of drugs so they can go out
there and play without the limitations
of pain no doubt about it it's it's it
is it's the dirty little secret of the
nfl i don't think it's ever going to
stop it's it's yeah there's a danger
aspect to it but at the same time
good luck telling an nfl football player
who's 26 years old they can't play or we
can't administer you know this shot
anymore he's you know nfl players they
don't care i know i'm banged up put that
thing in there you know stick the needle
in there i'm playing today
and that is just part of the game but
yes it causes injuries it causes more
issues it causes guys to go out there
with injuries they play they get the
toradol they think oh i feel pretty good
and meanwhile they're just numb and they
can't feel that yeah their shoulder that
was hurt is actually getting worse and
that's why you see sometimes guys get
hurt
they come back for like a week and then
also they disappear for three or four
weeks because they were rushed back too
much they got the numbing agent and they
thought they were okay to play that
really just caused more damage because
they couldn't feel that body part that
was hurt just continuing to get crushed
and banged up and everything like that
yeah here's dr needle with that syringe
full of toradol and other potent
narcotics but don't you dare smoke
marijuana to manage the pain or
to to you're getting there with the
stress i know i know yeah but they've
they've essentially decriminalized it
from the standpoint of they won't
suspend you but they'll still take a lot
of money out of your paycheck if you
fail enough tests so hopefully they get
to a point where they just take it off
the board all together it shouldn't be a
collective bargaining issue it shouldn't
be about who's got power who's got
leverage it should be about doing the
right thing and when you consider the
potency of the medications they give
these guys to allow them to play let
them smoke the damn marijuana if it
helps them feel better if it helps them
physically feel better mentally feel
better emotionally feel better so they
can go out there into that meat grinder
again again and again
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports